We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a voicemail that came in and I'm getting
more and more voicemails like it.
Take a listen.
Hello, Mr. Duckman.
His show.
Here's some you might want to consider.
What happened with coronaviruses is so bad
when it comes to a merchant class.
How will people get out the vote and vote
him out if nobody show up for the polls?
Something to think about.
Have a good day.
Yeah.
So this is something that people have been
e-mailing me, which is saying, you know, we
understand that actually postponing the presidential
election is insanely unlikely.
But if you have disproportionately people
on the left who are taking the quarantining
more seriously than people on the right.
If this doesn't get better by the fall and
you have Republicans who increasingly think
Trump is doing a good job dealing with Corona
virus, isn't that a situation ripe for Republicans
going out to vote to reelect Trump and Democrats
staying home?
Partially because they are following quarantine
orders.
I don't know the answer, but that is a concern.
That is a concern.
The postponement of the election is unlikely.
The impact on the electorate, though, is something
that is concerning me.
And I don't have an answer.
It will certainly be thinking about and talking
about this more as we as we approach November.
Real quick reminder, tomorrow, March 25th
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time will be the David
Pakman Show Chess Tournament.
All viewers and listeners are welcome regardless
of skill level.
Register on chess dot org for a free account,
it's free.
And tomorrow night I will be livestreaming
my participation in the tournament and I know
there are at least some chess players in our
audience.
I hope we get at least 50 people playing.
Maybe we'll get more and I invite you to participate.
If you're sitting at home bored, nothing to
do.
Participate in The David Pakman Show Chess
Tournament.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about what defines a business
as essential and much, much more.
Get a membership or pledge unpatriotic to
get instant access to today's bonus show.
People very impressed by the way, with Pat's
ping pong table, a punching bag setup at his
home studio.
You'll be able to see that again on today's
box.
I'll speak to that.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.